a lot of people say that I mean
obviously Vladimir Putin says that part
of the reason the invasion had to happen
is because of security concerns over the
expansion of NATO
and
there is a lot of people that say that
this was provoked by NATO
do you think there's some legitimacy to
that case
look I think the whole situation here is
very complicated you have to take a much
longer view than you know what happened
in you know 2008 with the open door for
Ukraine and Georgia which actually by
the way I thought was a strategic
blunder just to be very clear because it
wasn't any kind of thinking through
about what the implications of that
would be and you know what would
actually mean for your current security
and also bearing in mind what you know
Putin had already said about NATO
expansion they they came on the wake of
the recognition by the United States per
unilaterally of Kosovo and it also comes
in the work of mentioned before the
inversion of Iraq which really because
very
important for understanding Putin's
psyche
so I think you know we have to go back
you know much further than it's not just
talking about kind of NATO and what that
means
NATO is part of the whole
package of Ukraine going in a different
direction from Russia just as so as the
European Union remember the annexation
of Crimea comes after
Ukraine has sought an association
agreement with the European Union
not with an Airtel at that particular
Point even though you know the EU on the
security common security defense policy
um basically house all kinds of
connections with NATO you know various
different levels of European security
front it was all about Europe and going
on a different economic and political
and ultimately legal path because if you
have
an association agreement eventually you
get into the Aki committee turn and it
just transforms the country completely
and Ukraine is no longer the Ukraine of
the Soviet period or the Russian Empire
period it becomes you know on a
different trajectory like
Czech Republic Slovakia Poland you know
another country it becomes a different
place it moves into a different space
and that's part of it but if you go back
again
to the period at the very beginning of
the 1990s after the dissolution of the
Soviet Union well there's no discussion
about NATO at that point in NATO
enlargement
there is a lot of pressure again as I've
said before by nationalist elements on
Ukraine trying to bring it back in the
fold
I'm wanting to make what was then you
know this mechanism for divorce more of
a mechanism for remanaged the
Commonwealth of independent states
and in the early 1990s when
Ukraine became an independent state it
inherited that nuclear Arsenal from the
Soviet Union basically whatever was
stationed or positioned in Ukrainian
territory at the time became Ukraine's
strategic and you know kind of basically
intermediate and tactical nuclear
weapons and you know in the United
States at the time you know we had all
this Panic about
what was going to happen with all of
that I mean I think you know I was a
scientist and you know kind of
technically would have been difficult
for Ukraine to actually use this I mean
the targeting was you know done
centrally they were actually stationed
there but nonetheless Ukraine like
Belarus and Kazakhstan to become nuclear
powers
and you know ashkata the former U.S
defense I could use just died tragically
and not Dave was talking about
um you know uh uh talking together today
was part of a whole team of Americans
and and others who
you know tried to work with Ukraine
Belarus and Kazakhstan to get them to
give up the nuclear weapons
and back in the early period of that 93
94
you go back and I mean I was writing
about this at the time I wrote a report
called Back in the USSR which is you
know kind of on the website of the
Kennedy School with some other
colleagues
and we were monitoring how there was all
these accusations coming out of of
Moscow the defense um Ministry and the
Duma the the Parliament and others that
ukrum was trying to find a way of making
a dirty bomb using its nuclear weapons
you know becoming a menace um and you
know kind of Ukraine might have to be
brought to order
so a lot of the Dynamics we're seeing
now were happening then irrespective of
NATO
basically the the problem was always
Ukraine getting away Yeltsin himself
when he unraveled the Soviet Union
didn't really want it to unravel but he
didn't have the wherewithal to bring you
know the countries back again Russia was
weak after the collapse of the Soviet
Union its economy imploded
um it had to give sovereignty to all of
these constituent parts of the Russian
Federation in terms of the sort of
devolution of authority it had the war
in chechnya which Yeltsin stupidly
sparked off in
1994. you had Tata Stan one of the the
regions the old Rich regions
um you know basically resting out a kind
of a a bilateral treaty with Moscow you
had the whole place was kind of seemed
like it was falling apart so that you
know you couldn't do anything on Ukraine
because you didn't have the wherewithal
to do it and then when you know kind of
basically Russia starts to get its act
back together again all of these
security uh nationalist types who would
never want to Ukraine or Belarus or
Moldova or anywhere else to kind of move
away they didn't worry that much about
Central Asia to be frank but they know
they did want you know the um the core
States in their view to come back and
Moldova was part of that even it's not
Slavic but you know they wanted Belarus
and Northern Kazakhstan and probably
Kazakhstan as well which wasn't really
thought about being as part of Central
Asia back in the fold as close as
possible so anything that gave those
countries an alternative was seen as
negative
uh it you know could have been an
association with China you know of them
joining you know kind of an association
with Latin America or Africa or
something else like that but of course
NATO has all of those larger
connotations of it being you know the
Cold War uh opposing entity and Putin
has always seen NATO as being the direct
correlation of the Warsaw Pact which is
in other words just something dominated
completely by the United States
now that of course is my getting back to
Trump again Trump was always going you
know to the Europeans if this is really
supposed to be collective security in a
mutual defense pact why are you guys not
paying you know why does the United
States pay for everything but you know
NATO was actually conceived as
collective defense you know Mutual
Security and it was set up by you know
the United States along with the UK and
France and you know Germany and turkey
and you know other countries and we see
that now with the entry of Finland and
Sweden they didn't have to join it or
they didn't want to join it a long time
they wanted to partner with it just like
Israel and you know the country's
partner with um NATO but once they
thought that their security was really
at risk they wanted to be part of it
and so you know kind of you're now
really seeing you know that note was
something other than just being
um you know a creature or an instrument
of the United States but that's how
Putin always saw it so you know what
this debate about Metro is all about or
Russia being provoked
is wanting to kind of return to an old
superpower
bipolar relationship where everything is
negotiated with the United States it's
to try to deny that Ukraine or Belarus
well Belarus has been absorbed by this
point you know by Russia or Moldova or
Kazakhstan or any of the other countries
have any kind of agency not even Poland
or Hungary or you know kind of France
and Britain
for years and years and years
senior people like Putin and people
around the Kremlin have demanded a
return to the kind of what they call the
little concert of Europe or the concert
of Vienna where the big guys
which now means the United States and
Russia just sit down and thrash
everything out
and so I mean Putin by saying look it
was provoked it's the United States it's
NATO it's a proxy war or it's it's this
or it's that or this is going to be a
nuclear confrontation it's like the
Cuban Missile Crisis the Euro Missile
Crisis it's basically just saying you
know I want to go back to when the
Soviet Union the United States worked
things out I want to go back to the
whole you know period of the 1980s when
Gorbachev and Reagan just kind of got
together and figured things out or even
better back to Yalta Potsdam and Tehran
and the big you know meetings
at the end of World War II where we
resolved the whole future security we've
had a war we've had the Cold War now
we've got another War we've got a real
war Hot War we've got a war in Ukraine
it should be the United States and
Russia that sort this out so this is
where we see the United States waffling
about as well trying to kind of like
figure out how to handle this because
it has to be handled in a way that
Ukraine has agency because if Ukraine
doesn't have urgency and nobody else has
urgency either nobody else has any kind
of decision-making power
and you know we have an environment in
which Putin thinks that there's only
really three players there's the United
States and Russia and China and maybe
even occasion might be India and perhaps
Brazil or some other South Africa or
some other country like maybe the brics
at some point but you know ultimately
it's like the oldest big Powers resolve
everything and so this war is also about
Russia's right Putin's right you know to
determine things you know strong man to
strong man big country to Big Country
and you know determine you know where
things happen next that's why he's
talking about things being provoked it's
been the United States fault but aren't
there parts of the United States
establishment that likes that kind of
three-party view of the world oh there's
always going to be people who like that
part that
that which of course there is
then they don't necessarily dominate
that's the kind of thing that people
can't think about I mean you know Putin
can you know read you know all the
various articles and hear the kind of
pronouncements of people but you know
this gets back to you know the way that
the United States operates
you know Putin saw that you know Trump
wanted to have a you know top-down you
know vertical of power
and other presidents have wanted to have
that but the United States is a pretty
messy place and we have all kinds of
different viewpoints now of course we
know that in Russia everything even
criticism the Kremlin is usually fairly
orchestrated usually to kind of flesh
out you know what people think about
things when we had these hardliners
saying you know we needed more
destruction of Ukraine not less and that
you know the Army wasn't doing enough it
was in many respects you know kind of
encouraged by the Kremlin and to see how
people would react to that you know to
kind of actually create a constituency
for you know being more ruthless uh than
you had before because you know they
wanted to clamp down in the United
States I mean I can say whatever I want
it doesn't mean that I'm speaking on
behalf of the White House
and you know even if I have been an
advisor to this present that president
and the other doesn't mean I'm you know
basically speaking on behalf of the US
government but this is kind of always an
assumption from the Russians that you
know when people
you know say this and people do Advocate
one thing or over another that they're
you know it's operating there's a lot of
mirror Imaging thinking that you know
we're operating in the same kind of way
so yes there are of course
constituencies who think like that would
love it you know back to that and there
are many people out there with their own
peace plans
all kinds of people you know up there
yeah to push this there does seem to be
uh the engine of the military-industrial
complex seems to give some fuel to the
Hawks and they
seem to create momentum in government
yeah
they do too I mean there's a there's
always you know kind of a check I mean
again you believe in the tension of
ideas I think there was a lot of tension
I mean I've seen it I've seen it inside
of the government now you know and
people can push back and that's why I
speak out and I try to lay it out so
that everybody can you know kind of
figure out for themselves I said the
same to you as I say to everybody this
is how I see the situation and you know
this is you know how we can analyze it
here now look do I think that we've
handled you know the whole Russia
accounts you know fears
well no we haven't I mean we've we've
we've taken our eyes off the ball many
times we've fail to understand the way
that people like Putin think you know
you talked earlier about you know we
need to have empathy for you know all
the people who like Trump or like Biden
and some other thing we've got to have
strategic empathy about Putin as well
we've got to understand how the guy
thinks and why he thinks like he does
you know he he has got his own context
in his own frame and his own rationale
and he is rational he is a rational
actor in his own context we've got to
understand that we've got to understand
that he would take offense of something
and he would take action over something
it doesn't mean to say that you know we
are necessary to blame by taking actions
but we are to blame when we don't
understand the consequences of things
that we do and act accordingly or you
know take preventative action or
recognize that something might happen as
a result of something